- Good afternoon everyone.
I'm Peter Salovey, the
President of Yale University.
I--
(audience applauding)
You know, I love the fact that that line
still gathers applause, you know?
There will come a day when it won't.
(Peter laughs)
Well on behalf of the
trustees of Yale University,
the faculty, and everyone here at Yale
and in the New Haven community,
it's my honor to introduce
Ambassador Samantha Power.
Ambassador Power is here on
campus today as a Chubb Fellow.
Hendon Chubb was a 1895 graduate
of Yale's Sheffield Scientific School
and in 1936 he made a substantial
gift to the University
to encourage our students to
take an interest in public service.
Since 1949 his endowment has been used
to underwrite a prestigious
visiting speakers program
bringing extraordinary
public figures to the campus.
The Fellowship is
administered by the Master
of Timothy Dwight College, who
is currently Jeffrey Brenzel,
who you will see later in the program.
(audience applauding)
Past Chubb Fellows have included
four presidents of the United States,
presidents of eight other countries,
and more than 150 other
regionally, nationally,
and internationally prominent individuals
noted for their distinction
in service to the common good.
I'm especially delighted to introduce
Ambassador Power today for two reasons.
First we are celebrating her homecoming.
She earned her bachelor's degree
in history from Yale in 1992
and I found that one of
the great pleasures--
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
I don't know if those are
all the history majors
or the class of 1992 but,
(audience laughing)
we found one of the greatest pleasures
and privileges in the Yale presidency
is the opportunity to
welcome back graduates
who have distinguished
themselves in the world.
In this particular case I confess
to having a personal stake in the outcome.
Ambassador Power was a student
in my psychology class.
(audience laughing)
I don't know whether she
has been able to apply
anything that she actually
learned in that class
in the years since but I'm happy now,
perhaps happier that she
might have been at the time
to make careful note of the fact
that she was one of my students.
The second reason it is a special pleasure
to welcome Ambassador Power today
is that collectively Yale
owes her a debt of gratitude.
I would put it this way,
she has chosen to do with her life
what we aspire to prepare
all of our students to do.
She has taken maximal advantage,
both here and elsewhere,
of the privileged
educational opportunities
that her capacities and
circumstances presented to her
and she has fully embraced
these opportunities
in order to accomplish
extraordinary things,
both with respect to the life of the mind
and to the life of the world.
Most of you know that Ambassador Power
has combined in an
unusual and powerful way
the careers of an academic
and a public servant.
While in law school at Harvard
she began writing a paper
that became her Pulitzer Prize winning,
and immensely influential book,
A Problem from Hell: America
and the Age of Genocide,
published in 2002.
It has been said of this book
that it influenced more young people
and in particular more women
to devote themselves to studying
and working in human rights
than any work published before or since.
In an often told story,
we know that the book also moved
the then Junior Senator
from Illinois, Barack Obama,
to meet her for dinner.
From there her story accelerates.
Staff member to Senator Obama,
Foreign Policy Advisor to
the presidential campaign,
Special Assistant to the President,
and Senior Director for
Multilateral Affairs
and Human Rights,
US Permanent Representative
to the United Nations,
the youngest-ever at age 43,
and throughout her rapid rise
to positions of accountability
and influence, Samantha
Power has demonstrated
a remarkable commitment to probing
the often troubling relationship
between the prerogatives of power
and the obligations of power.
Here at Yale we are grateful and honored
to have her as a member of our community,
where once she came to
study in our classrooms,
today she has returned to offer us
her own instruction and wisdom.
Please join me in extending to her
our own warm welcome back to Yale.
Ambassador Power.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
Thank you so much
for doing this.
- Happy to do it.
So nice of you to join us.
- Thank you.
(audience applauding)
This is not the welcome I get
when I walk into the UN
Security Council every morning.
(audience laughing)
I should come here more often.
It's wonderful, truly wonderful,
very moving for me to be back.
I came to Yale from Atlanta Georgia.
I went to a public high
school in Atlanta Georgia
and being here it is
no overstatement to say
that being here completely
changed my life.
It was an amazing experience,
many of my teachers are
here, who I still think about
even as I do my day job.
I went from wanting to be a sportscaster,
which would have been a very worthy career
and still I pine for it at times,
(audience laughing)
to wanting to do something, anything,
in American foreign policy
because of the teaching
and the inspiration
that I got from the Yale faculty
and from my fellow classmates.
I will say that I never
ever, ever, ever imagined
that I would come back to Yale
to speak as the UN Ambassador,
so it's thrilling for me.
Thank you.
We are living in a time,
it is very fair to say,
of daunting and perpetual crises.
The deadly spread of Ebola in West Africa,
a string of shocking executions by ISIL,
more tanks and heavy armaments
rolling across Ukraine's border
to Russian backed separatists,
barrel bombs and chlorine being dropped
by the Assad's regime on Syrian civilians,
child soldiers being abducted
and forced to fight in a brutal civil war
in the world's newest
country, South Sudan,
the list goes on and on.
There's so many crises that
when we turn our attention
to working to bring one
of these under control
or trying to reduce the suffering
that a particular crisis
is causing two more pop up.
At a different time in our history
we may have felt tempted to
ignore some of these threats,
we may have thought that
we wouldn't pay a price.
In 1776 Thomas Paine wrote that, quote,
America, remote from all
the wrangling of the world
may live at ease, bounded by the ocean
and backed by the wilderness,
what hath she to fear
but her God, end quote.
But in today's interconnected
world we don't have the luxury
of remoteness from the world's wrangling.
It can impact us more swiftly
and more deeply than ever before.
Now this is not news to any of you,
you see it, you feel
it, you understand that
America cannot afford
to ignore these threats
and at the same time you understand that
today's threats are so
immense and so complex
that even if the United
States wanted to tackle
any one of them alone, we
would not be able to do so.
We need to rally the international
community to our side.
The point I want to make to you today
is that in addition to leading
the international community
in responding to these
threats in real time,
we need to help shape a
world where such threats
are like less likely to
arise in the first place.
This sounds so obvious, I know,
and yet generations of policymakers
across the political spectrum
have struggled to dedicate
the bandwidth, financial resources,
and diplomatic and political capital
to make these long-term investments.
As someone who came into
government fully convinced
of the critical importance
of seeing beyond
the crisis of the moment,
I can tell you that it is
surprisingly challenging
in practice to do so, given all else.
But my message to you
today is that we cannot
treat the short and long term
as an either/or proposition.
We have to try to put out a lot of fires
in the here and now,
but we can't let the
immediacy of today's crises
distract us from playing a smart long game
that will create more stability
and more security in the long run.
Let me offer a few examples,
curbing the spread of Ebola,
protecting the rights of women and girls,
and countering violent extremism.
On September 18th the
United States chaired
the first-ever emergency meeting
of the UN Security Council
on a public health crisis, Ebola.
By that time more than 2,500
people had died of the virus
and some 5,500 had been reported infected
in Guinea, Liberia, and Sierra Leone.
A Liberian health care
worker named Jackson Naimah,
who was working at Medecins
Sans Frontieres, Ebola Clinic
in the capital of Monrovia,
spoke to the council via video link.
He described people
dying outside the gates
of the clinic where he worked
because there were just no
more beds to take them in.
He said, quote, "I feel that
the future of my country
is hanging in the balance.
If the international
community does not stand up
we will be wiped out," end quote.
Now the United States has done
more than any other country
to help West Africa respond
to the Ebola crisis.
The CDC deployed teams to
the region way back in March,
shortly after the outbreak began.
In July President Obama declared
controlling the epidemic
a national security priority
and most importantly days before
that September Security Council meeting
the president announced the largest
global health intervention in US history,
resulting so far in the deployment
of more than 3,000 US civilian
and military personnel
from the Department of Defense, US Aid,
the CDC, and other agencies.
We're supporting the construction
of 15 Ebola treatment
units, so called ETUs,
and brave and brilliant men and women
in the US Public Health
Service Commissioned Corps
provide Ebola treatment
at a 25-bed hospital
built by the US military
and dedicated to treating
healthcare workers
and Ebola responders
who contract the virus.
This ensures that medical
volunteers and UN personnel
from around the world will
receive top-notch care
if they are infected while working
on the front lines of this epidemic.
The United States is training hundreds
of Liberian healthcare workers
at a newly built center in Monrovia,
and countless more through
mobile training teams
traveling to remote areas.
But even with all this we know
that the United States alone
cannot curb the epidemic's deadly spread.
That's why we mobilized
133 other countries,
the most in the history
of the United Nations
to co-sponsor a Security Council
resolution declaring Ebola
a threat to international
peace and security.
It's why President Obama
personally launched
a full-court press to mobilize commitments
from other countries,
keeping heads of state around
the world on speed-dial
to convince them to do more,
and it is why we are now
holding other countries
to the commitments that they have made
and pressing those who
have committed too little
or who've committed nothing
at all to do their part
because we will not defeat Ebola with a
some hands on deck effort.
Having visited the most affected countries
at the end of October I can
tell you that we are beginning
to see the impact of
our collective response.
In Bong County, Liberia I visited
a US Navy run Ebola testing lab,
which had cut the time local Liberians
waited for test results from five days
to between three and five hours.
On November fourth only 33 out of 53
Ebola affected districts across the region
had the ability to transport samples
to a lab within 24 hours
of collecting them,
according to the WHO.
By November 17th, just 13 days later,
all 53 districts had that capability,
and lab testing time matters
because the sooner you get your results
the sooner you can leave facilities
where you might be waiting with people
who are actually infected
and in many of these labs
about 70% of the results
are coming back negative,
so actually a large number of people
who are being tested are not
those who in fact have Ebola,
they may have malaria, they
may have some other ailment,
that allows them to leave
and it frees up bed space
for those who need to
be isolated with Ebola.
The results affirm what we have
said all along about Ebola,
which is that we know
how to win this fight.
We can bend Ebola's deadly curve
but bending that curve is
very different from ending it.
It would be a huge
mistake to think that just
because we are seeing signs
of progress in some areas
that we are close to stopping
this outbreak, we are not.
In Sierra Leone the
disease is spreading faster
than at any time since the outbreak began,
with more than 900 new infections
reported in the two-week period
that ended November 23rd.
Some 16,000 people have been reported
infected in West Africa
and more than 5,500 people have died.
The actual figures are likely
in fact to be much higher.
Local contact tracing
teams outside of capitals,
which are critical to breaking
chains of transmission
continue to lack basic resources,
like gas for their motorcycles,
or even credit for their SIM
cards on their cell phones,
and the human toll is staggering.
Think for a second about
the heartbreak associated
with any one of the 4,000 boys and girls
who have lost a mother or father
to the virus, 4000 orphans,
or the incalculable loss
of warmth in countries
where people used to hug when they met
but now are told not to wipe the tears
from the eyes of a sick child
in case the child might be infected,
or the pain experienced by the people
who have beaten the virus,
only to find themselves
stigmatized or even run out of town
by their friends and their communities
when they attempt to go home.
Yet in spite of all the suffering
the outbreak has caused,
and it is immense,
and in spite of the virus's surge
in parts of the affected countries,
we have to find a way to
look beyond the outbreak
and ask what factors made
these countries so vulnerable.
We have to take steps now
so that in the long term
we avoid finding ourselves
in this situation again.
One reason Ebola spreads so fast was
because West Africa had never experienced
an Ebola outbreak before
and even before the virus surfaced
public health systems in Guinea,
Liberia, and Sierra Leone
were stretched beyond capacity
just to meet the day-to-day
needs of their citizens.
Prior to the outbreak Liberia
had approximately 50 doctors
for the entire country
of 4.3 million people.
That's around one doctor
for every 100,000 people.
Sierra Leone had two doctors
The United States by
contrast has 245 doctors
for every 100,000 people.
The United Kingdom has 279, Germany 380.
Yale New Haven Hospital, which is just one
of nearly 50 hospitals
in Connecticut alone
has more than 600 resident physicians.
Liberia had 50, before Ebola.
The Yale New Haven number is
12 times the number of doctors
in all of pre-Ebola Liberia.
The Yale School of Medicine graduates
over 10 times the number of
doctors in a single class
then worked in Liberia before Ebola began
taking some of the country's
best nurses and doctors.
Ebola has killed approximately
330 healthcare workers
in West Africa, many of
whom were not working
to treat Ebola when they were infected,
but rather were providing
routine medical assistance,
such as delivering babies.
The affected countries also lacked
and in many instances continue to lack,
protective suits and even plastic gloves
to keep healthcare workers safe.
They lack lab capacity,
emergency operation centers,
and disease surveillance systems.
Communities were not aware
and some are still not aware
of what Ebola is or how it is spread.
All of these deficiencies meant
that when the Ebola
outbreak hit these countries
it hit harder and spread faster.
Leaders and communities in the region
understand the importance
of plugging these gaps.
They understand the dangerous,
short sightedness of
thinking our job is done when
we end the current outbreak.
They know what epidemiologists'
research proves,
another outbreak whether of Ebola
or of another deadly disease
like SARS or MERS is inevitable
but whether these outbreaks become
full-blown epidemics is up to us.
When I met with President Ellen
Johnson Sirleaf in Liberia
on my trip to the region
and asked her what keeps her up at night,
she said it was the
country's restless youth.
Three-quarters of Liberia's population
is under the age of 35.
She said she worried about kids
who've been out of school for months,
about young men and women
who've lost their jobs
since Liberia's economy
started its ongoing decline.
One out of every two
Liberians who was employed
at the beginning of the
outbreak is now out of work.
Seven in ten people surveyed
said they do not have
enough money to buy food.
President Conde of Guinea
and President Koroma of Sierra
Leone voice similar concerns.
So did so many of the community
and civil society leaders
I met with in all three countries.
They were worried that
making it to, Ebola free
will quickly translate
into these countries
being assistance free.
As we in the international community
quickly pack up and leave behind countries
with far greater insecurity
and far weaker economies
with thousands of orphans children
and public institutions in shambles.
Recognizing these acute risks,
we are now looking beyond ending
this Ebola epidemic's curve
to preventing the next
infectious disease epidemic.
Back in February, before
the first cases of Ebola
in Guinea came to light,
the United States launched the
Global Health Security Agenda, the GHSA.
The Agenda's aimed at preparing countries
to prevent, detect, and
rapidly respond to outbreaks
before they become epidemics.
During a meeting with
President Obama in September
43 countries joined us in announcing
over 100 specific
commitments to strengthen
global health security,
together with the WHO
and other international institutions.
The GHSA is predicated
on the understanding
that in a world where an outbreak
that begins in the forests of Guinea
can quickly spread across
borders, continents,
and even oceans, a
weakness in any part of our
interconnected global
health security system
is a threat to us all.
We and our partners have
set out 11 areas of focus
to strengthen national,
regional, and global capacity.
These include boosting immunization rates
to stop the resurgence
of preventable diseases,
ensuring countries have
nationwide lab systems,
capable of conducting rapid accurate tests
to detect outbreaks early,
and developing and
implementing the real time
disease surveillance systems
and the workforce required
to track outbreaks,
like the contact tracing
teams that are so critical
to tracking down those who
might have had physical contact
with someone infected with Ebola.
Each area focused within the GHSA
has a five year implementation plan,
which sets out concrete
benchmarks along the way,
and a way to measure them.
To meet crises head-on where they are,
we are also developing
new regional partners,
such as the African Union's own
Centers for Disease Control,
which the AU and the United
States agreed to jointly create
during this year's
US-Africa Leaders Summit
and our own CDC is helping
to advise and build.
We're also investing in
the young policymakers,
innovators, and civil society leaders
who will lead their
countries in responding,
not only to this kind of
crisis but other crises.
Whether inside or outside of government
these individuals will
do the yeoman's work
of shoring up institutions
and making societies more resilient
and less vulnerable to global
threats like epidemics.
This is why President Obama launched
the Young African Leaders Initiative,
which brought its first class of
500 Mandela Washington
fellows to the United States
to study this past summer.
20 of our nation's top universities,
including Yale, I'm proud to say,
hosted Mandela Washington fellows
for six weeks of leadership
training, skill building,
and networking with their peers.
Some of you in the audience
may have had the chance
to hear from these fellows
about their remarkable work,
often done in the most
daunting circumstances.
One of the Mandela Washington
fellows in this year's class
was Sarah McGill, a 28 year old Liberian.
When Sarah returned home this
fall, she noticed a problem
because of the exponential spread of Ebola
when Sarah went shopping in Monrovia
all the stores had signs
outside telling people
to wash their hands in
chlorinated water before entering.
Most shops had a five liter bucket outside
and at the busier businesses
the wait could take up to ten minutes.
During that time people
crowded into long lines
when they were at greater
risk of infection.
Others gave up and left
costing the stores business.
So Sarah designed a simple 440 liter tank
with six individual stations,
which permit multiple people
to wash their hands at once
and 'cause the tank is much larger,
it only needs to be refilled once a day
as opposed to every few
hours with smaller buckets.
16 communities are now
using this simple tank
that Sarah designed and
more plan to build them,
particularly outside of schools,
enabling potentially
schools to open back up
and the necessary precautions
to be put in place.
Investing in a problem solver like Sarah
and all of the young problem solvers
in this audience tonight, has
to be part of our long game.
Now I've been on campus for
about two and a half hours
and I've already gotten
an administration's worth
of policy recommendations today
from Yale students and faculty.
Thank you for that,
but let me offer one to you
and to take advantage of the leadership
who is present here today.
I would urge you not only
to host future classes
of Mandela Washington fellows,
but also to deepen your
engagement with the initiative
by sending Yale students, faculty members
and researchers out into the field
to partner with the fellows
who have studied here.
Dartmouth, which also
hosted fellows in 2014,
has started a program like this
and its first batch of
students are on their way to
Tanzania, Ghana, Angola, and Zimbabwe
to work with fellows this winter.
Of course Ebola is not the only crisis
where it is in America's interests
and the world's to play the long game,
even as we respond to immediate threats.
Another is advancing the
rights of women and girls.
We've got to address the immediate crisis
of widespread gender-based violence,
particularly in wartime,
while at the same time
making the crucial long-term investments
in the empowerment of women and girls.
Violence against women during conflicts
is anything but a new problem.
One of the earliest accounts
of the mass abduction of women and girls
can be found in Plutarch's Parallel Lives,
where the seizure of Sabine women
played a central part
in the creation of Rome.
Plutarch wrote, armed with swords then,
many of Romulus's followers
kept their eyes intently upon him
and when the signal was
given drew their swords,
rushed in with shouts,
and ravished away the
daughters of the Sabines.
Some say that only 30 maidens were seized
and that from these the curiae were named,
but Valerius Antaeus
puts the number at 527
and Juba at 683, all maidens.
We know that violence
against women and girls
in conflicts persists
with disturbing frequency,
yet the statistics
and the horrifying individual
acts continue to shock.
Consider the Democratic Republic of Congo
where sexual violence has long been used
as a tactic of war in the
decades-long conflict.
In one of the most devastating incidents,
at least 387 people including
300 women and 55 girls
were raped by armed groups in
13 villages in Eastern Congo
between July 30th and August 2nd, 2010,
just a three-day period.
While conflicts exacerbate such violence
it is a daily fact of life
for women and girls around the world.
One in three women is the victim
of physical or sexual
violence in their lifetimes.
The UN estimates that 150
million girls worldwide
experienced sexual violence each year.
In Sao Paulo, Brazil's largest city
a woman is assaulted every 15
seconds, according to UN Women
and in many places the problem
is getting worse, not better.
In Honduras the number of
violent deaths of women
increased by 263% from 2005 to 2013,
yet in 95% of sexual violence crimes
and killings of women in Honduras,
the perpetrators are never punished.
There are immediate steps we can take
to stop violence against women and girls,
both during conflicts and in peacetime.
We can improve accountability
for violence against women
and girls through strengthening
documentation of abuses
and the capacity of justice officials
to prosecute perpetrators.
Physicians for Human Rights
created a mobile app, MediCapt,
which it piloted this year in the Congo
and which converts standardized
medical intake forms into
a way to gather forensic
documentation for prosecutions.
When a medical professional
fills out the form using the app
it is immediately turned
into a digital record
which can be used by
prosecutors to trace patterns
and build cases against perpetrators.
The app can be used with a digital camera,
allowing medical
professionals to supplement
their written reports with
photographs of key evidence,
such as physical bruising.
For this evidence to be useful,
countries need prosecutors
who are capable of building
cases upon such evidence
and judges with the independence
to punish powerful perpetrators,
yet these are basic institutions
that many countries,
including the Democratic
Republic of Congo, still lack
and this is why in June Secretary Kerry
announced a new accountability initiative
to support specialized
justice sector mechanisms,
such as mobile courts, to
improve access to justice for
survivors of sexual and
gender-based violence in conflicts
and to help build the judicial capacity
of partner governments.
As you all know, the
struggle for accountability
must not only be waged in conflict zones,
like the Congo, but also
here in the United States,
including at our colleges
and universities.
An estimated one in five women
has been sexually assaulted
during her college years.
Of those assaults only 12% are reported
and of those reported assaults
only a fraction of the
offender's are punished.
That is why President Obama
established the White House Task Force
to protect students from sexual assaults.
In April the task force released a report
with recommended steps
that schools can take
to hold offenders accountable
and support survivors.
This struggle needs to be
waged not only by women
but also by men.
That's one of the messages behind
the President's and Vice
President's It's On Us campaign,
launched recently to stop
sexual assault on college campuses.
As a proud Yale graduate I'm
often amazed by the leadership
and the service of Yale
students and graduates,
but rarely am i as
impressed as I have been
with how students here have
taken up this challenge,
moving far beyond making a pledge,
to bringing together
leaders from across campus.
From Yale's College Council
to communication and consent educators,
from the Yale Women's
Center, to sports teams,
and acapella groups, to build a campaign
that makes everyone on this campus ask,
how can we change our behavior
and our community to
live up to the pledge?
How can we work with the administration
to bring about stronger
enforcement and accountability?
How do we make this part of our Yale?
That's exactly what
It's On Us is all about.
At the same time, far from US campuses,
we have to make UN Peacekeepers
better at protecting
women and girls from sexual violence.
One way to do that is by
improving early warning systems
for sexual violence and other atrocities
and proactively pursuing repeat offenders.
Peacekeepers in the Congo
have set up alert networks
that allow communities to report threats
and attacks in real time
directly to UN peacekeeping bases
so they can intervene
and the UN created a special
unit in its Congo mission,
the Force Intervention Brigade,
which has made real headway
disarming and defeating
the armed groups responsible
for some of the worst
atrocities, including mass rape.
Yet the sad fact is that even
when peacekeepers are warned
they often fail to act.
A March report by the UN's
Internal Oversight Office
found that in 507
attacks against civilians
from 2000 to 2013 peacekeepers
virtually never use force
to protect civilians under attack.
This is totally unacceptable.
To address the problem the United States
is working to ensure peacekeepers
have both the capacity
and the will to protect
civilians under attack.
In August President Obama announced
the African Peacekeeping
Rapid Response Partnership
or A-PREP, which will
invest 110 million dollars
each year for the next three to five years
to build the capabilities
of six countries,
Ethiopia, Ghana, Rwanda,
Senegal, Tanzania, and Uganda,
which have embraced a more
robust approach to peacekeeping
and we are building a global consensus
among all peacekeeping countries,
including the most skeptical ones,
about the critical importance
of actually implementing
civilian protection mandates,
including by protecting women and girls.
That is what the short game looks like
in stopping sexual violence
against women and girls,
but of course if we want
to move beyond protecting
women and girls from abuses,
to empowering them to
realize their full potential
we need to do much more.
It will come as no surprise to you
that education is the
linchpin of our long game
in women's and girl's empowerment.
We know that education
is a smart investment,
not only in the girl's future,
but also in the future of their nations,
as countries that do a
better job of educating girls
are on average more prosperous, healthier,
more democratic, and more peaceful.
That is not a coincidence.
Yet while it is all well and good to say,
we need to ensure girls'
right to an education
and educating girls is one of the
smartest investment societies can make,
getting girls into the
classroom and keeping them there
through secondary school takes much more
than making school compulsory
or building classrooms.
Just look at the numbers
62 million girls worldwide
are not in school,
more than 30 million of
them in sub-saharan Africa
where there is so much promise.
To tackle this problem we need
to change the mental models,
attitudes, and behaviors that lie beneath
this persistent imbalance.
For instance in Tanzania
four out of every ten girls
are married before their 18th birthday.
That's because according
to a recent report
by Human Rights Watch, many
communities across the country
see marriage as a way to protect
girls from premarital sex
and pregnancy, both of which are seen
as undermining a family's honor.
In addition as we know brides' families
receive doweries from grooms' families
giving them a strong incentive
to marry their daughters early.
As a result girls are married off young,
forcing many to leave school
and even those who stay
in school after marriage
are often pressured by
school administrators
and family members to drop
out when they become pregnant.
Girls who marry early are more vulnerable
to a range of other abuses,
including domestic
violence and marital rape.
It is impossible to ensure
more girls in Tanzania
find their seats in the
classroom and hold on to them
without these societies
tackling the underlying beliefs
and practices that are
driving girls from school.
That means changing
attitudes and communities
about child marriage and dowries,
and convincing educators to find ways
to allow pregnant girls
to continue their studies.
Behind every one of the
obstacles to girls' education
is a fear or prejudice
that we must address.
It is fear of empowered women
that drives extremist groups
to abduct girls from their classrooms
as they did with the Chibok
schoolgirls in Nigeria,
and fear that drove them to try to kill
this year's remarkable Nobel
Prize winner, Malala Yousafzai,
for daring to champion girls' right
to an education in Pakistan,
and it is deep-seated
prejudice that causes families
to see educating their daughters
as less important than
educating their sons.
The only way to overcome
these obstacles to empowerment
is to challenge the dangerous idea
that a girl's education is
a privilege or even a threat
rather than what we know
it to be, which is a right.
In some instances changes
in the belief systems
underlying these practices can be
fostered by public policies.
In West Bengal, for example,
a political affirmative action program
put women leaders in village
government for the first time.
Within seven years men's individual bias
against the capacity of women leaders
almost fully disappeared.
Seeing women leaders in
positions of authority
also gave parents higher
aspirations for their daughters
and raised girls
expectations for themselves,
and we know full well
that the developed world
needs public policy oriented around
girls' and women's empowerment, as well.
Last week Germany passed legislation
requiring the country's leading companies
to have at least 30% of the membership
on their executive
boards be held by women,
up from the current level
of approximately 7%.
This in a country led
by a female Chancellor
with a Parliament that is
approximately 40% female,
which is more than double the
proportion in the US Congress.
When we invest in
empowering women and girls,
the results come full-circle.
Women and girls who are better educated
can demand more accountable
justice systems,
which are more effective at
prosecuting cases of sexual violence.
They will also be better
informed about their rights
and thus be better equipped to defend them
and to demand redress
when they are violated.
It makes her a virtuous
positive feedback loop
by investing in empowering women and girls
we help create societies
where the sexual violence
against them is less likely to occur.
By playing the long game reduce the need
to play a short game.
Now I've spoken to you
about the importance
of looking beyond stopping
the current Ebola outbreak
to how we can prevent similar
outbreaks in the future
and I've spoken about
how in addition to taking
immediate steps to end sexual violence,
we also need to invest more fully
in women's and girls' empowerment.
In both instances the threat
in front of us is so urgent
and the suffering it
causes is so devastating
that it can be easy to lose
sight of long-term investments.
This problem of being
consumed by responding
to the here and now of a
crisis is especially acute
with regard to the final
threat that I want to discuss,
violent extremism.
The violence and suffering caused
by violent extremist groups
calls out for our immediate response,
making it particularly challenging
to maintain a focus on the long term.
In a time when we wonder if we have
lost our capacity to feel horror,
the barbarism of these groups
continues to sicken us.
In its vicious campaign
against the Yazidi people,
ISIL continues to abduct women and girls,
hold them captive, and
rape them systematically
before auctioning them off
like cattle at markets.
Last week in northern Nigeria
in a series of attacks
bearing the hallmarks of Boko Haram,
45 people were killed
by two suicide bombers
in a crowded marketplace
and at least 120 people
were killed by bombs
and gunmen in an attack on a major mosque.
It goes without saying that
because terrorist groups like ISIL
pose a threat to Americans,
and to international peace and security
we must rally other
nations to confront them.
This is why in May the President launched
the Counterterrorism
Partnerships Fund at West Point
to build the capacity of our partners
on the frontlines in this shared effort
and why the United States
has rallied over 60 partners
to a global coalition to
degrade and defeat ISIL.
Many of these partners
are already contributing
in concrete ways, whether
through military support
or through addressing the
humanitarian catastrophes
that ISIL's terror has helped create.
Another critical part of
responding to this threat
is stopping the flow of foreign fighters
who increasingly fill the ranks
of these extremist groups.
Suicide bombers not only from Fallujah
but also from Florida,
fighters not only from
Peshawar but from Paris.
It is estimated that more
than 16,000 foreign fighters
from more than 90 countries
have traveled to Syria
since the conflict began, 16,000 people,
and this includes many people who hold
American and EU passports.
President Obama has taken the lead
in addressing the threat posed
by foreign terrorist fighters.
In September he chaired a
UN Security Council summit
at the UN on this problem,
in which Member States committed
to taking decisive steps
including stopping the flow of funding
and enacting national laws
to make it more difficult
for these fighters to join such conflicts.
But if we do not play the long game
in addressing the hatred
fueling these groups
and the reasons individuals
are drawn to their ideology,
the waves of extremists will keep coming.
Here Syria offers an important lesson
because when we look
at the Syrian conflict
we are reminded that ISIL's barbarism
has been fueled by the
barbarism of the Assad regime.
A regime whose ongoing
atrocities continue to be
ISIL's most fertile recruiting tool.
A regime that during Ramadan
calibrated its bombing runs
to coincide with the times and places
where Muslims were
meeting to break the fast.
A regime that dropped chemical weapons
and barrel bombs on unarmed civilians,
a regime that is responsible for
torturing thousands of detainees,
and documenting their torment
in harrowing photographs,
whose victims were given serial numbers,
and their torture, starvation,
and killings meticulously documented.
So those who argue that we
must work with the Assad regime
to vanquish the threat
of ISIL are wrongheaded
about this being productive
for American interests.
Not only would partnering with Assad
go against what America
stands for and believes in,
it would be a huge boon for
extremism in the region,
and the world.
In Syria the enemy of our enemy is not
and will never be our friend.
The lesson to be drawn
from the Syrian conflict
is one that can be applied
far beyond its borders,
extremism thrives in places
where people have no hope,
where brutality is systematized,
where impunity is emdemic.
Extremism grows in dark
places where there is no hope
or light to let other ambitions grow.
Tackling violent extremism also requires
lifting up the voices of Muslims
and people of all faiths
who denounce terrorist acts
committed in the name of Islam.
In September, 126 Muslim
scholars sent a letter
to the head of ISIL saying,
it is forbidden in Islam
to kill the innocent.
It is forbidden in Islam to
kill emissaries, ambassadors,
and diplomats, hence
it is forbidden to kill
journalists and aid workers.
It is forbidden in Islam to
harm or mistreat in any way
Christians or any people of the scripture.
It is obligatory to consider the Yazidis
as people of the scripture.
The reintroduction of slavery
is forbidden in Islam.
Now I didn't hear about
this letter when it came out
and chances are neither did you,
and neither did so many people,
particularly in the Muslim world,
to whom the letter is also directed.
I first heard about it a few weeks ago
when the UN High Commissioner
for Human Rights,
Zeid Ra'ad al-Hussein, also a Muslim,
read it before the Security Council.
He also told the Council
of ISIL's attacks, quote,
"The authors of these crimes are people
whose actions are nothing but disgusting
and whose consciences have demonstrably
been annihilated," end quote.
More messages like the cleric's
and like the High
Commissioner's need to be heard.
In addition to lifting
up the voices of Muslims
who denounce terrorism,
we also have to close
the detention facility at Guantanamo Bay.
The facility should never have been
opened in the first place and
continues to make us less safe
and to undermine our
standing in the world.
Years ago the Supreme
Court rejected the premise
for opening GTMO, which was that detainees
would not be able to
challenge their detention.
The vast majority of detainees
once held at Guantanamo
have been transferred, including 530
transferred under the
previous administration.
As a US diplomat I
can't tell you how often
other governments point to GTMO
as a way of defending
their repressive practices
or how much its sustained
existence continues to weigh
on our relationships with
close partners and allies,
and extremist groups
continue to use Guantanamo
as a propaganda tool to recruit those
who seek to do us harm
and as a justification for
their abhorrent violence.
President Obama has made clear
his desire to close Guantanamo,
but since 2009 Congress
has imposed restrictions
that have constrained
our ability to do so,
including placing limits on our ability
to transfer detainees to foreign countries
and imposing a prohibition
on transferring detainees
to the United States,
even those we have the capacity
to effectively prosecute for their crimes.
Another argument should not be necessary
but please listen to this one.
The United States is spending
nearly half a billion dollars
annually to operate
the detention facility,
which currently holds 142 detainees.
That works out to roughly three
million dollars per detainee
per year or approximately thirty times
what it costs to hold a prisoner
in a federal supermax prison.
The kind of facility from which
no prisoner has ever escaped.
That same half a billion
dollars could be spent
training nurses to stop the
spread of Ebola in West Africa
or investing in girls' education
in Nigeria or Afghanistan,
or strengthening aviation security
and information-sharing tools
to track down foreign terrorist fighters,
or any of the other long-term investments,
domestic or international, that
too often gets short shrift.
Now at times it can feel
as though the United States
is shouldering an unfair burden
in responding to global threats
and that the American
people are the only ones
being asked to make sacrifices to try
to ensure a more secure and stable world,
but we are not.
We live in a world full of people
willing to put everything on the line
for the future of their
families, their nations,
and by extension for
the world that we share.
That dedication is what drove so many
of the young Liberians,
Guineans, and Sierra Leoneans
that I met on my recent trip.
People risking their lives,
as well as alienation
from their communities
by volunteering to serve in
the Ebola treatment centers
and in the burial teams.
As one young volunteer
told me in Freetown,
the capital of Sierra Leone, quote,
"If we leave our brothers
and sisters to die
who knows, it might be us next.
It is a point of duty," end quote.
It is what continues to drive schoolgirls
in northern Nigeria to
show up to class every day,
girls who are not willing to let the fear
of seeing other girls
kidnapped by extremists
keep them from claiming
their right to an education,
and it is what drove the fearless
Libyan human rights
defender, Sawa Bugaighis,
to stand up for the rights of her people
despite constant death threats,
first under the Gaddafi regime
and later from extremists.
On June 25th, 2014 Sawa
urged her fellow Libyans
not to be intimidated by extremists
who had threatened to attack
anyone who voted in
parliamentary elections.
She even posted photos of
herself casting her ballot
on her Facebook page to show
that she would not be cowed
by the death threats she
had received or by fear.
She was killed that night.
All of these people, the
Jacksons, and the Sawas,
and the Nigerian school girls,
and so many others are our
partners in the long game,
and they have high expectations,
not just for themselves but for us.
They believe that the
United States will live up
to our highest principles
by standing with them.
They believe that we will prove worthy
of wielding the tremendous responsibility
that comes with our tremendous power.
That we will not only play the long game
because it is in our
self-interest, which it is,
but because we believe
it is right to advance
the dignity of people around
the world, which it is.
It is and must be a constant
struggle for all of us
to live up to these expectations
and to live up to these principles.
In the United States and
abroad people recognize
that this is a struggle
that the American people
have embraced and that we who have
the privilege of representing
them must embrace as well.
It is the constant struggle
that makes us who we are.
It is why our partners and the
world expects so much of us
and that is not a burden
that weighs us down,
it is a wind that lifts us up.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you, very much.
I'm Jeff Brenzel
I'm the master of Timothy Dwight College
and the Steward of the Chubb Fellowship,
and knowing the stress
and strain of Ambassador Power's work,
not to mention the
relentless sense of urgency
that rises up to meet her every day,
I'm both impressed and
grateful that she came today
to participate in a class
here with Paul Gewirtz, Jake
Sullivan, and Harold Koh,
has stayed to give this University
Chubb Fellowship address
and we'll have dinner later
with 120 undergraduates.
- Don't forget the reception.
- And the reception.
(audience laughing)
- I like what she said
then about the long game.
Hendon Chubb and the
many prior Chubb fellows
would applaud her investment here today
in you and in us.
I hope she will see a
return on the investment,
both from those inside and
those outside this room.
We're privileged to have her here,
we're privileged in general,
and that privilege brings its obligations.
Let's hope that we can
seize our opportunities
in the ways that she has seized hers.
So let's have a few questions.
You see two microphones here in the aisle.
If you have a question
please make your way to
those microphones now.
Some of you are positioned
advantageously for this
and because time is
short please do your best
to speak briefly and ask a clear question.
Okay, thanks very much
and Nicole because you're a TD student,
we'll start with you.
- [Nicole] Thank you very much Miss Power.
A recent profile of you
in the Vogue Magazine
has your friend and a former
colleague of yours saying,
people with Samantha's
moral compass and compassion
don't usually make it
to such ranks of power.
My question follows on from that.
I've always respected your
ability to criticize governments
and other bodies, both
abroad and at home in the US,
but your position now as a
representative for the US
requires I assume that
you defend and promote
the position of the US even
when it might be against
or different to your
own personal position,
or even when it is criticized by other
human rights organizations.
I wanted to know if you could please speak
to the challenges holding such a position
with such constraints versus say,
being an independent journalist.
- Great, thank you.
- Easy one.
- Yeah.
I was hoping when when the
question started by quoting Vogue
I was hoping we were trending
in a good direction but.
(audience laughing)
Let me just, I think the
best way to answer it is
just to describe the
blessing that I feel everyday
being particularly in
the job that I'm in now,
getting to represent the United States,
I'm an Irish immigrant to this country,
getting to sit in front of the placard,
having the weight of our
diplomatic resources,
and our means and our soft
power behind me everyday,
on behalf of the same causes
I champion my entire life,
from you know the basement
of Beinecke Library
or you know wherever I was
working on a given day.
I mean, in the old days when
I wrote a column for instance
I used to have a column at Time Magazine
or if I wrote a long New Yorker piece,
my hope was that someone at a
much lower level than mine now
would read that and would
bring it into the meetings
and try to inject a
perspective from the field,
from, you know, from people
who could speak to the ways
in which policies were
affecting real people
far from, as it were, the boardroom
or far from the bureaucracy.
So I just feel very incredibly privileged
to be able to take that perspective
and I just give you a couple examples
of how I think bridging
those worlds can be
really powerful and important.
One I mentioned already, Jackson Naimah,
the Security Council
occasionally brings in people
from outside UN officialdom
but relatively rarely still
and when we did this meeting for
the first, again, emergency meeting
on a public health crisis in
the 70 year history of the UN.
There'd been a really important
AIDS Security Council meeting before
but to think how you puncture
what people are bringing,
the preexisting alibis,
and biases, and
indifference, or even concern
but misinformation or whatever that people
are bringing to this meeting,
and to find a Liberian health
worker who actually was
the person at the gates
having to turn people away
'cause there just weren't enough beds,
and for him to describe what it was like
to tell a father that no he
could not deposit his child
in the Council, if I have the
chance as the UN Ambassador
to bring Jackson's voice
into UN Security Council
deliberations which are usually, you know,
a little more robotic, I mean,
and if the price is simply that having
argued for something
internally and not succeeded
that I you know get to go
out and still defend the US,
I mean that's a very modest price to pay.
Another example is we pushed
the Obama Administration,
pushed hard to try to
get the crimes in Syria
referred to the
International Criminal Court
and Russia cast its fourth veto
in the Syria context over that issue
and you know, when I was
sitting down with my team
to think about how can we
capture the stakes of this
and this is an not a story of success
from a policy standpoint,
but nonetheless, there
are all of these people
out there in Syria
who've been barrel bombed
by this regime, bee tortured,
have been gassed with sarin,
and now with this veto
that's coming tomorrow,
the Russians will prevent
those crimes from ever being
or for the time being
anyway being adjudicated
or prosecuted in court,
so we tracked down a
chemical weapons survivor
and I was able to say to the council
and to my Russian colleague
and Chinese colleague,
who also vetoed, you know, unfortunately
because of these vetoes today the ICC
will not be able to hear the testimony
of people who survived the
chemical weapons attacks.
It would be left to a
court normally to decide
what is true and what is false,
but here is the testimony of one person
who would have liked to testify,
and I just, in his own
voice basically described
what had happened to him
and brought, we ended up
being able to bring him in
to the Security Council Chamber,
and he and others again it's
small compared to the veto
which was so devastating
but to be able to inject that
perspective into deliberations
again is the privilege of a lifetime,
compared to to writing a column
and again hoping someone
will read my column,
I'd take this any day.
- [Audience Member] In
thinking about the long run
is US diplomacy doing anything to separate
the followers from the
leadership of the terrorist group
and somehow welcoming them
back into civil society?
- It's an excellent question.
I mean, I think that there
are a number of programs
now that exists including a
very noteworthy one in the UAE
which is for people who have chosen
to leave violent extremist groups
and I think thinking through
not only the pressure side
of the equation, namely
what are the disincentives,
you know what are the
rewards that can be placed
for the arrest or capture of individuals
who are behind very nefarious plotting,
but thinking about how to
pull away those followers,
whether through social media
and places that they're
very, very active to try to,
right now, the terrorists in ISIL
have taken significant advantage
of social media platforms
and it's really important
that we who are trying to
contest that message,
but not just we the the kinds of clerics
that I described in in my remarks,
that they are taking advantage
of those platforms as well,
and pulling them away.
So we're drawing on on everything
in the Department of Homeland Security,
in the Department of Justice,
across the US Government,
in terms of the State Department
and our public diplomacy
to try to project messages
of the kind that you're describing,
which is that there is a place to go
and that you're not, you
know, that at a certain point
you're not too far gone.
On the other hand if
people have been part of
executing American journalists
and you know, the kinds
of horrors that have been
perpetrated in Syria and Iraq,
you know, we also have responsibilities,
particularly to American
citizens to pursue prosecution
and so forth, so, you know,
I think separating out people
who have been instrumental
in violent acts against civilians
from those who sort of thought
it might be a cool idea
to go to Syria for you
know, their school break
and then got stuck there, we need a way
and to continue to strengthen
the ways of distinguishing.
- [Audience Member]
Ambassador could you comment
on the United Nations
conference on climate change
that is starting this week in Lima, Peru
and also give us your projection
as to how the result of
that conference might be
implemented by the President
and by the Congress.
- Thank you.
Well one of the reasons
that President Obama
and the Chinese Premier
made the announcement
that they did, when they
did, was to try to inject
into that conference momentum
out of the bilateral agreement
that we reached with China
and I will say now as
a somewhat of a veteran
of multilateral diplomacy,
having worked on it for four
plus years at the White House
and now been in my current
job for more than a year,
often the best ingredient for successful
multilateral diplomacy is
strong bilateral agreements
that then amalgamate,
and so you know, for the
United States and China
to make commitments of that nature,
not only in terms of emissions reductions,
as the two largest economies,
as the two major emitters
but also for the United States to make
such a substantial commitment
on the funding side
for those countries that are
already feeling the effects
of climate change and
there's just the cost,
and I hear this from small
island countries at the UN
is it's as poignant as hearing about
abuses carried out in peacekeeping.
I mean it's just hearing
whole villages disappear,
livelihoods eradicated and so forth.
So we attempted to bring
that momentum into Peru.
I'm not going to make any predictions
because these conferences
are very hard to predict
but we have a number of bites
at the apple between now
and you know, the ultimate goal
for something more comprehensive.
Thank you.
- [Audience Member] Well
first I'd like to thank you
for giving such a convincing argument
for why the United
States should play a role
in supporting liberty
and freedom in the world,
but my question is that
you talked a lot about
the, like, if not for tests
and evaluating humanitarian interventions,
and a lot of these wars like Iraq,
and some of the other ones
have been billed as humanitarian,
have given humanitarianism as a bad name,
and have made the American
people understandably frustrated
with you know, excursions,
foreign excursions.
So can you explain it
how you think, well you,
and the government in general,
or the Obama Administration
or future administrations
can convince people or
convince the American people
that the United States has
a role to play in the world
beyond just protecting
its national security.
- Well, I think first of all we have to
pull apart the like and the unlike,
and it's very challenging to do this,
but you know, try to distinguish
one particular set of
circumstances from another.
So for instance the
circumstances that existed
prior to the war in Iraq back in 2003
were ones that President
Obama then, you know,
of course not president,
but nonetheless, did not find convincing
as warranting the deployment of US forces
and an intervention without
Security Council authorization
and a lot of the sort of foreseen negative
international reaction which I believe,
as he put it at the time,
was going to have
implications on the back end
also for how much support one would get
in sort of seeing through the mission.
That is a very different
set of circumstances
from the set of circumstances where ISIL,
a group with, that makes very explicit
its genocidal intention toward
Shia, toward Christians,
toward Yazidi, forcing people to convert,
raping people, enslaving people,
executing American
journalists who they know
have done no harm other than to try
and document the suffering
of the Syrian people,
so drawing those distinctions,
yes it turns out there
are military operations
in both instances in Iraq
but there are also substantial difference
in terms of the the imminent threat
posed by in the case of
the the current effort
by you know, something that
we haven't seen before,
which is a terrorist movement
controlling large swaths of territory
and massive heavy weaponry.
You know, much of which
it, and oil fields, right?
I mean, so it's again, just to to isolate
both the intentions, the actions,
and the resources and
capabilities of this movement
and make the case on those grounds
and I think notwithstanding
the very, very understandable
fatigue in this country
from being involved
in war for so long in
Iraq and Afghanistan,
the public support for
this effort against ISIL
I think speaks to the fact
that that distinction was drawn
and that people accept that these
are two different circumstances.
It doesn't mean that they're not concerned
or that they don't raise issues
that have to be taken very, very seriously
about you know, ending
up in a different place
but in terms of this
again, campaign in support
of Iraqi efforts to to
rollback ISIL's gains
and ultimately degrade and defeat ISIL
there's a lot of support.
The other thing we need to do though
that I tried to do a little bit tonight
but we need to do more of
is when something is working,
as for instance our intervention
in Liberia is working,
it's not succeeded, it's not
close to having succeeded,
but it is having measurable
demonstrable effects
for families in Liberia
and ultimately having
important effects also
for the security the American people.
We need to be sure that
we are communicating
that effectively to the American people.
You know it is, it is
unfortunate, somebody who has
maybe some bandwidth to
do this can look at this
but you know, the amount of coverage
that the Ebola epidemic
got in the period where,
before our interventions in
Liberia started to take effect
versus the amount of coverage that,
I mean, again it's normal
but it's not desirable from the standpoint
of the American people actually knowing
the return on the investment
that they are getting
by virtue of what our heroic forces
and CDC epidemiologists, and aid workers,
and diplomats are doing.
I mean, so we have to tell that story
and I try to do that wherever I can
but that's a part I think of
ensuring that the American
people have confidence,
not only in the that we have
the right objective as the government,
but also that we have
the ability to achieve
the objectives that we lay out,
and that that confidence
is an important part
of sustaining our
international engagement.
- Okay I'm going to
apologize for the folks
that have been standing in line
because I think we're going to be able
to do two more questions so--
- You know, why don't
we hear from everyone
and I'll just take a couple of them
and at least your fellow audience members
will have heard from them.
- All right, rapid-fire.
- Rapid-fire.
(audience laughing)
- [Audience Member] Oh God, no pressure.
(Samantha laughs)
So, you spoke a little bit
about how important it is
for the United States to
partner with other nations
to promote peace and security.
How do you deal with the
challenge of balancing
trying to cooperate with
countries like Russia or China
that we agree with on some
issues and want to work with
but then on the issue
of Syria or in Ukraine
or the conflicts in the South China Sea
we diverge, how do you balance
those two different issues?
- Yes.
- Oh.
After hearing you talk about the obstacles
to women's education outside the US
I can't help but just feel amazingly lucky
to get to go to school, you know, at all
and especially at a place like this
and I'm wondering if, you know,
given all the experiential learning
that has happened for you
between the time you graduated
Yale and where you are now
is there anything you learned here
either academically or socially
that's really made an impact
on how you do your job?
- [Audience Member] I'm
wondering if you can comment
on the future of the responsibility
to protect doctrine given the challenges
of intervening in Syria?
- [Audience Member] Two great
historical events in my life,
when I met my wife,
that was the number one,
and number two, the formation
of the United Nations.
Can you give us some
idea of what's going on
to make the United
Nations a more efficient
and organization in terms
of reforms of various types?
- [Audience Member] I
appreciated your words
about global threats
requiring global cooperation
in the context of Ebola
or fighting the threat from
returning foreign fighters
and I'm wondering what you think
in the next few decades
will be the challenges,
limits, and benefits of
empowering regional partnerships,
not just in the US and India
or direct bilateral relations
for things like the climate deal
but directly empowering regional powers
to be presences in their regions
and to deal with some of the and issues
and guide in ways that
the US may not be able to
or willing to in the next coming decades?
- [Audience Member] First of
all I wanted to say thank you
'cause I know you're a
big inspiration to me
and probably many in this room.
I've heard World Fellow Rami Nakhla,
who's an activist in
Syria speak frequently
this semester about the
nature of the ISIS problem
being not just something
that's a short-term solution
but as you said long game
and something that relates very strongly
to the power vacuum in Syria.
So I was wondering if
you could talk more about
what the frontier is on that issue
because most of what I've
heard is very cynical
and that it's just
something that's going on
but I know that you've written obviously
about how America responds
in the age of genocide
and what you think the next step is?
- [Audience Member] So you
spoke a little bit about
how Islam does not support
the actions of ISIS
and so I was wondering why
we're still calling it ISIS
and rewarding it by
branding it with the name,
you know, of a religion
that supports, you know,
that's a good religion with good people.
So I just, yeah, thank you.
- [Audience Member] Ambassador
thank you for being--
- They would have us
call it Islamic State,
they would have us call it,
I mean that is their their
current title for themselves
but anyway go ahead, sorry.
- [Audience Member] With the
Millennium Development Goals
set to expire and the
Sustainable Development Goals
being next on the agenda,
I'm wondering what you see
as the greatest challenge
in those negotiations
and which countries the United States
is going to need to engage
to achieve its objectives.
- [Audience Member] You so much
for being here, Ambassador.
Given that 2015 is the 100th anniversary
of the Armenian Genocide, I'm
wondering what your feelings
are on how the UN will approach that
and whether this will
be a time to bring up
more or less publicity
about genocide in general
and whether this anniversary is
an important thing for
Americans to also be aware of,
given that there's a
large Armenian population
but also given the many other genocides
that have happened since that time.
- [Audience Member] Hi, my question
is more about your background.
You were a journalist
and you were, had just graduated from Yale
when the Yugoslavian genocide began,
you saw the Rwandan genocide,
and you saw the UN system fail,
and now as being part of that system
how does that inform your role in the UN,
particularly with intervention?
- Mm-hmm.
- [Audience Member] Thank
you so much for being here.
My own studies have focused
on gender promotion in Rwanda
which have been to a degree successful
through a combination
of the country's size,
political well,
and the fact that it's post-conflict.
Of course you look at places like the DRC
where violence and conflict
themselves have become endemic.
How do you combat kind
of gender-based violence
in those situations?
Thank you.
- [Audience Member] My question
is about genocide also.
I count probably two major instances
in the current administration
of the word genocide
being used very publicly
and very impactfully in Benghazi
and then earlier this year
surrounding the Yazidis in Iraq
and I would like you to just maybe briefly
give a retrospective grading on the
administration's use of that term
and whether it kind of fits in the model
that you would think is appropriate
for the use of that term
and whether or not you
think it's maybe broader
than just one president
or one administration
and if it reflects a
broader institutional change
by the US Government
and the way it uses that term
and how that term is used to affect
broader action in the world?
Thank you.
- One more.
_ Thank you, Ambassador.
I just want a question, how can the US
alongside the United Nations
block any future military,
kind of, I would say a war
kind of, between the Israelis
and the Palestinians.
How can we block a future
Israeli raid on Gaza
and killing civilians, thank you.
- So Ambassador Power,
I'm gonna be deeply impressed by the way
that you pulled this off.
- No, you won't be.
- And I know that in advance
and also I think we've
got enough material here
for another visit next
week, don't you think?
(audience laughing)
- Okay first let me say one reason
I think that was the right thing to do
is just what an amazing,
what an amazing group of students,
definitely the standards have
gone up since they let me in.
(audience laughing)
So there's not one of those questions
I would have been capable of asking
when I was here as an
undergrad but nonetheless,
now I'm stuck answering them.
So let me,
what I think I'll do is just,
I'm actually not gonna try
to tick on each of them
but I will, I want to just say a few words
about the issues that
haven't come up yet so far
and then just encourage those students,
I don't recall exactly
where we're going next
but we have some next on
the Grateful Dead Tour,
we're making our way to the next venue,
and then people who don't feel
I was responsive to their question
I'm more than happy to engage,
but one because I think it's a question,
the very first question one about
how we continue to work
everyday with Russia,
notwithstanding Ukraine, and Syria,
and these very divisive issues.
I think it's just a question
that's been on a lot of people's minds
so I'll take that question.
I think the answer is that each of us,
that the United States and
Russia each have interests
that we want to see advanced in Syria.
For instance, our interests in,
that are very much overlapping,
should be overlapping with Russia's,
preventing foreign
terrorist fighters flow,
preventing terrorist groups
from gaining a foothold,
preventing chemical weapons use,
those are our interests
and those are why we have
taken the policy positions
that we have, very much alongside
preventing the slaughter
of innocent families, which
is happening every day.
Russia has at least some
of those shared interests
but their route to
advancing those interests
is very distinct from ours
and that is what creates
the clash that we have seen
and the vetoes that I've mentioned.
In other words they
view Assad as the route
to achieving many of the
objectives that I've described
and sort of just accepting
his rule in perpetuity
as being in our collective interests,
which they would characterize,
but at the same time we are in gridlock
in the Security Council over Syria.
We are working side by side
in the P5+1 negotiations
to try to come up with
a comprehensive deal
that would deny Iran a
pathway to a nuclear weapon
and Russia has participated
constructively in that.
By the same token on
many, many Africa issues,
whether South Sudan or the
Central African Republic,
or Mali, you know, they, you know,
issues where their immediate
interests may not be at stake
but they still vote in support
of peacekeeping operations
or in support even of sanctions
designations and so forth.
So there's a fair amount
of cooperation on issues
not related to Syria and
Ukraine that goes on in New York
and it's very useful for our interests
that that is the case.
Our cooperation the Security
Council will never lead us
to pull our punches however on
human rights abuses inside Russia
and the kind of over brazen aggression
that we've seen in Ukraine.
So there are tensions in all
of that, as you can imagine.
In terms of just flagging
a couple other things
that hadn't come up.
I think the Millennium
Development Goals is something
a lot of students on
campus were interested in
and got a lot of traction,
these goals for kids being
in school, for malaria,
for you know, a whole host
of social and economic goods
and they've had a stickiness
particularly in the health area
that has been very, very important.
Our biggest challenge in
negotiating the successor goals
to the MDGs is the success of the MDGs
because these goals became actionable
and resources have been
deployed around a set of goals,
measurable targets,
if you have an issue that matters to you
and you're in this negotiation,
you want that issue represented
in the new set of goals
because you believe that it will mean
that you get the resources that you need
and every country is bringing
this kind of attitude to it.
In other words the stakes
are seen as extremely high
but the results right now
is a very, very long list
and he who fights every
battle risks fighting none,
so the biggest challenge is
because of the success
perversely of the MDGs
and the faith that people have
injected in this new process,
it will be challenging, very challenging
to discipline the list.
The last thing I'd say just
in terms of what I learned
academically or socially, nothing
socially, that's for sure,
but I would say, I mean, the amazing thing
about being at Yale was opening up,
we used to have this thing,
this is ridiculous that
this is no longer the case,
but we used to have the Blue Book
and opening up the Blue Book--
- [Jeff] It's still there.
- Yeah but it's online, doesn't count,
it's nowhere near the same.
It was just this, it would come
and it was this amazing
euphoric experience
where your eyes were so
much bigger than your tummy
and you wanted to take
everything and learn everything
and inject yourself into
a whole host of domains
that you had no business
being in, in some cases
but I think that's the spirit,
that spirit of believing that you can
both learn, you know, which
can be a burden, it's hard,
particularly in competitive
environments like this one
and love it.
I think that is the thing
that I took from here
and I've just been extremely privileged
in my professional career
to constantly learn
and also just love it
and bring that expectation every day that
we can be inspired by our work
and even if we're not succeeding always
in just the way we like
that to have the privilege of trying
is you know, just a great, great blessing.
So the Blue Book spirit
that I take to my day job,
I think is what I would share.
Anyway with that.
- [Jeff] Thank you, very much.
- Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Well once we get out here,
we can get on a schedule.
- I think if we do.
(gentle music)